each year Microsoft research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely
available okay so we're going to get
started uh I want to thank everyone for
coming today to our workshop on Quantum
algorithms and devices uh we have a
really exciting day lined up I have to
say I'm really excited to see so many
new faces in the audience um that we did
not expect such a crowd so looks like
you have to get to know your neighbors
today um we did uh we had a Quantum
session at The Faculty Summit for the
first time last year and it it was
really popular and a hit so we had a a
second session this year uh so this is
the second time we've had a workshop in
conjunction with the faculty Summit and
I have to say this year it looks like we
we have about double the crowd so this
is really exciting and I hope it kind of
shows how uh more popular how much more
popular Quantum Computing is becoming uh
here at Microsoft and also in the
academic Community uh so thank you
everyone for coming um we had a great
Quantum session yesterday uh with talks
from Rob schulof David Riley and Dave
Wecker uh today in the middle session uh
Rob and David are going to give us a
more technical detailed talk um on the
hardware devices and the control
engineering required uh so that will be
uh that'll be great uh this morning we
have uh a series of talks um where we're
going to learn about what you can do
when you have an untrusted quantum
computer uh so that that that should be
exciting um then this afternoon we'll
hear a little bit more about some work
in Quantum
algorithms um what we can learn about
SpaceTime from Quantum
information um also new applications to
uh material
uh how we can use quantum algorithms to
explore Material Science uh and so on so
it should be a really exciting day uh
thank you again everyone for
coming and I think we'll just get
started so uh the first talk we have
this morning uh is from yaan Shi and
yaan is going to talk about true random
true Randomness it's Genesis and
expansion so let's welcome
yaan thank
you thank you Christa and thank you uh
all of you to be here and um and it's
very an honor to be here uh and I've
been a a theorist all my uh professional
career and that I'm in a company talking
about my work uh make me feel that my
work actually is relevant to reality so
that's so thank you uh very
much so uh Randomness means different
things to different people so I will
start by describing uh uh what I mean by
Randomness and why is it difficult to
get
Randomness and why we should consider
Quantum approach for generating random
numbers and in particular uh using
untrusted Quantum
devices so what it's
Randomness suppose we have a unring x
and I I call random uh to with respect
to a Quant system e if the string X
cannot be perfectly predicted from uh
the system e so Randomness is
relative what time I have breakfast this
morning well I know it but it's random
to
you so uniform Randomness means that uh
the string X is uniformly distributed
and it is in tensor product with the
system e so there's no correlation
between X and
E NK Source means that the string X has
n
Bits but for the system e the best
chance of e predicting X is no more than
2 to the minus
K so if n is precisely k the only
possibility is this uniform Randomness
there's no correlation between
them and when K is strictly less than n
uh we call x a weak Randomness a weak
source of
Randomness so we'll be talking about
errors so by error I mean a deviation of
the joint State X and E from this
uniform
distribution
case uh deviation could be uh Trace
distance and I will be talking about
true Randomness what I mean is when
parameters of my protocols grow when I
use more
resources then this error will go to
zero that's what I mean by true
Randomness okay those are my
terminologies
so we need Randomness we need them a
lot Randomness is critical for
craphy
privacy and it's uh vital for running
randomized
algorithms uh for Sim simulating physics
for
gambling and I think we need so much uh
probably one terabyte a day in the whole
world is not a exaggeration I I saw bur
laughing I'm not sure do you think
that's reasonable or small maybe this is
too small okay at least L low B this low
B actually in fact um U most of
Randomness we use they don't come from
the keys the keys are only small portion
of it at least according to my security
colleagues so every internet packet uh
has a has a header which is supposed to
be a random
number um so the central question is how
do we get to
Randomness and know that we are getting
it the reality is that we are not always
getting true
Randomness and there are many security
uh problems in the Practical systems we
are
using I wanted to uh quote a a research
done by my colleague Alex hman and and
and his collaborators
hinger so uh they downloaded a lot of uh
Keys DSA keys and RSA keys from
internet they didn't try to factor uh
every one of the the key the public keys
but they try to look for paywise uh
shared factors and they ended up
breaking 1% or
1.5% of uh of keys
and the reason is because there are so
many key sharing factors with each other
now we know gcd is easy to to do
right and and there are small number of
device
makers probably 80% are in Taiwan um and
producing those uh Hardwares and they
all use similar methods to get a initial
Randomness so there just isn't enough
entropy to start with so there are the
problems we know from newspapers that uh
there are hardware and software uh back
doors for random L
generators so heninger and kther they
stated in their in their paper uh secure
random number generation continues to be
unsolved problem in important areas of
practice yes Matt you said that they
simply take a large number of of pairs
of keys and just run gcd
oh they didn't run the naive PIR wise
gcd but they essentially what what I did
they run a more clever algorithm now we
find out if there's any PIR share factor
they will find out that share factor
yeah it's a clever way of P wise gcd
they suspected that the cations didn't
have enough entropy that was
true so the primes are supposed to be
render but they are not sample randomly
that's that's basically theoretical the
theoretical reason why there are so many
share
factors so it's a difficult problem so
why is a difficult problem so here's a
cartoon uh Deber cartoon so uh this
random number Oracle is giving out its
Rand numbers and which is a sequence of
nine n n n n n doesn't seem random to us
but it's the same probability of
occurring with any other
sequence there's just no way to test if
an output is uniformly distrib it for a
simple reason uh because uh uh uniform
distribution is a convex combination of
deterministic distribution if I can call
it that way uh so there's no way to
differentiate these two
cases and it's also a deep mathematical
and physical
expression um it's not clear at all that
Randomness exist in the whole
world it's all possible that uh we all
this may may look uh terrible to some
people I apologize for that um but I'm a
fan of the movie um so you probably know
which movie I'm referring to U so it's
possible that we are all sitting in this
environment that we know we feel that
things are random but some higher being
knows what's going on right and we just
can't possibly know and it's possible
that quantum mechanics
is uh a correct theory of predicting of
our observ ation at the same time
everything is
deterministic uh there might be some
magic book having
every setup of experiment recorded and
then the outcome of experiment also
recorded already
deterministically and we are just
reading of that deterministic book is
possible reading it randomly H are we
reading it randomly no we are reading
deterministically and yeah it's random
to us but for this how being is
deterministic it took me a while to to
feel comfortable accepting quantum
mechanics correct at the same time the
war is could be deterministic um how
does your definition of Randomness
compare with say color complexity or
other definitions of Randomness yeah I
think it's very different korov uses
this program size to describe a
Randomness right uh the size of this the
smallest size of a program to uh
generate sequence you didn't Define what
a guess
was uh sure I can Define it so imagine
you have some classical string right
some secret X and I am Quantum I'm the
rest of universe okay and I'm trying to
predict your secret so what I can do is
to apply whatever local measurement on
my system and come up with the lumber
and that's my guess do I have to write
down next before you try to guess no I
don't know why you are so I know you
have
some string say and suppose I know the
length of a
string and I'm trying to come out with a
with a with a guess so you have X I'm
going to come out with X Prime X Prime
comes
from the measurement outcome outcome
that I get by measuring my own system so
I can choose the best measurement I
think so all your strings are fine not
dele my I have Corner system
I have a I have Quantum sign information
about your
secret you can even assume this say
infinite Dimension I think it works our
proof should work for that as
well so for our question to make sense
we have to assume there is weak
Randomness in the
world now assuming that the world is not
deterministic there's some weak
Randomness so now the question Bec comes
could there be almost perfect Randomness
assuming we have weak Randomness to
start
with so a negative answer to that
question would be maybe we we are stuck
with weak Randomness there's no way for
us to amplify Randomness to to almost
prefent
this so it's a it's a deep physics
question so let's look at how
people uh uh what are the the tools
developed in the past for for getting
true Randomness so there's a theory of
Randomness extractors uh developed in
80s studed in 80s and now is still very
active research
area so in this Theory weak Source we
sources they are modeled by Min entropy
so we describe the lens and the Min
entropy and the extractor is a
deterministic procedure so it takes
which sources and output some string so
that uh under some assumptions uh of
about those
resources the the extractor is so
cleverly constructed so that the output
is guaranteed to be trous so that's
classical
Theory and when one of the sources is
uniform but very short uh it's uh
there's a very short seed you start with
uh they are amazing constructions uh lch
constructions that guarantee very uh
good performance almost Optimal
Performance in the
output but there's a limitation to that
theory uh one main main major limitation
is it requires two independent sources
to start
with so in particular if there's only
one single Source in which case case we
call it deterministic
extraction then it's impossible even
just to get one
b and this was done by Sani in the
80s and this is
umani um so we require two independent
sources U and of course one of them if
one of them is uniform that is
independent of the other but they are
also constructions that uh neither has
to be uniform but they do need to be
independent if they only slightly
corated we can even extra one
bit it's it's impossible to check if two
sources randomly are
independent uh for the same reason I
pointed out earlier so um you have
independent distributions but a convex
combination of them could be highly
corated so there's no way just to tell
these two situations about
part and it's probably there's probably
strong correlation between these two
sources okay then um so this fundamental
limit is one reason that we should
consider Quantum
approach and of course there are more
reason to to to do that uh the most
important reason is so quantum mechanics
in this postulat uh has perfect
Randomness in it so if we prepare equum
State uh in uh the plus date and just
measure using computation basis we get a
perfect uh coin outcome and in fact
commercial products are
available and I want to point out that
trusting the quantum device so I'm
talking about trusted device uh random
number duration now and if we trust the
corner device it's actually a very
strong assumption it implies independent
Source because if you trust a device you
trust the state is the plus State and
you trust in measurement is doing
computation measurement then you get
perfect coin you get in particular you
can get independent uh uh bits out so
it's a stronger assumption than
Independence so this is a commercial
product I hope this slide will not annoy
anybody in the audience uh so this is
taken
from from from from the website of
idti I
doctorate it claim so this is a product
of the company for uh uh generating
random numbers using Quantum technology
I don't know what's inside I heard it's
based on photonics I'm not sure it's
right or not we open it and it's not
what you think it
does okay you have to look at the
pattern number and when you look at the
pattern then you know what's really
inside and not look at the web page I
see so now I'm I'm convinced that I'm
not going to annoy anybody after you
speak speak out yeah okay thank you for
that information right and we can we
don't know what this Quantum ah
okay good yeah that's interesting um
okay so I didn't open up I didn't look
at the pattern I look at what they said
okay they said that their device passes
all Randomness tests which I know is
mathematically
impossible and they also say it's
officially certified by some four lit
sorry one two three four five lit agency
maybe of switzland government ask me
what that means certified yeah I don't
know what it means mean they've been
asked to run one test Suite okay and
they certified that running that one
test Suite the answer is it passing that
one test Su I
see thank you for that information thank
you it doesn't mean that it's
random okay it just means they certify
that it passes that one test sure sure
okay good actually uh right so um I
heard that they sell a lot to casino
companies and that's precisely the those
Casino companies need that U there's
credability
certific exactly not the quantum exactly
exactly all the randomness yeah I have
another question how do you know this
state is
precisely 1 time K 0 plus 1 time K 1 I
mean you're asserting that it's on the
equator of the block spere with perfect
accuracy there's been no change
whatsoever the coin is absolutely Fair
doesn't have to that seems out
outrageous that's not needed I know I
know but I mean the claim that it's a
perfect generator passes all tests well
if I get uh 1% more ones than zeros when
I measure it that's a test that will
fail uh if it's not absolutely fair but
you can always apply B noyman strick you
can apply tricks the assumtion was the
thing is passes all tests there's a test
does it pass that no matter what I doubt
it yeah okay it did
not okay so that I I'm going to bring
out some similar doubts okay so how do
we know it works right it's the same
question you're asking actually so we
are not Quantum beings we are classical
beings we can't put our fingers into
that device and say wow this is
beautiful Show's cat State we can do
that and there's another question uh are
we willing to tr the manufacturer or the
certifying agency I guess after the
comment we probably will not so even if
yes we trust them uh the devices
themselves might not be reliable after
some time right so we're still facing
the question of uh how do we know this
thing is
working uh according to its
specifications so those considerations
motivated unet device Quantum uh
cryptography so in this model we
interact interact with L devices through
clal
interfaces and the devices themselves
might be
entangled uh with themselves and might
even be have been prepared by adversary
okay that's the worst case scenario that
we to deal with so there's no assumption
about inet working and device can be
imperfect or even
malicious so the question is can we
still reap the quantum benefits You by
using those untrusted cor
devices and the answer yes we can we
have to work with them and we can still
make use of
them so this area of untrusted devis
quantum cryptography started with the
question of quantum key
distribution and now it has a few
directions U I say Ben is going to talk
about a parel Clos rated direction of
untrusted qu computation in a sense
so our task is to create and expand two
Randomness using anased Quantum devices
so that's our
goal so I'm going to talk about what has
been done and introduce our model and
stay our
results so there are two lines of
research be before before our work uh
one is called Randomness
expansion uh studied by cobc In This
thesis uh a lat paper um appear
uh in uh a few years later uh with some
new
contents so here's setting so we have
some untrusted
devices and we start with some small
number of bits that are perfectly random
uh and making use of those
devices H with the help of the perfect
seed and then we hope to Output uh a
large number of output
bits so um there have been secured
proves uh in of against the classical
aniversary and in restricted Quantum uh
against the restrict restricted Quantum
adversaries and um the first Quantum
security was proved by basic in
2012 and so another amazing property uh
that V vitic proved is that the growth
of the lenss is exponential we start
with kit we get exponential in capit out
so U they have this two amazing uh
results so the second line of research
is called Randomness
amplification started by kobak and Rena
more
recently so they were motivated by the
question so those two were physics are
physics they they asked the question are
there fundamental Randomness in
nature so we need to model what is a
what is reg Randomness in nature so
here's their
model uh you have a sequence of events
each one is binary uh bits so each one
is a
bit and for every bit I the bit is run
has certain Randomness condition on
previous bits in the environment just F
about what it is so the chance of it
being one is between half minus Epsilon
and half plus Epsilon so Epsilon is a
parameter describing uh the weak
randomness of the
world so starting with this weak
Randomness and making use untrusted
quantum devices they were able to Output
uh one bit
of uh up high Randomness meaning close
to OB close to one half uh when the
length of the strings grow uh then the
closer that one bit will be to perfect
Randomness so a later paper by Gago and
cther show that this is true for any
Epsilon less than half so previous paper
shows that when Epsilon is small enough
you can you can amplify uh uh the
freeness uh of the Free Will and and
later paper show that as long as Epson
is bounded below B bound it about for by
one half then you can you can uh extract
one bit and a more recent paper reduce
the total number of devices to be a
constant so those works or assume
certain Independence of the source and
the devices it's just some Independence
assumption
there so I'm so those are those were two
lines of research before our work so I'm
going to present a a unifying framework
and we call it physical extractors so in
this
framework there are few there are four
entities the first one the protocol it's
deterministic
and uh there's this
aniversary which is quantum and all
powerful uh in the adversary may be
entangled with the devices and and and
he might have been the person making uh
L
devices but we have a restriction that
once the protocol starts there's no
interaction between uh the adversary and
devices we have to isolate those devices
is from the adversary and this is an
assumption that we also have in the
classical cryptography if you're doing
something secrety you have to record
that uh the components you are running
your algorithm on is they are not
sending out signals to
adversary all right the third entities
the third entity is the collection of
devices they are not interacting
interacting uh among themselves once the
protocol
starts and and in principle we could use
uh we could pull them far apart and and
relying on special activity to invol in
force no communication but in practice
it may be
difficult okay the
fourth actor in this game is uh this Min
source so this is a classical B string
that has
certain
uh
unpredictability to the adversary and
the
devices so the the main entropy of the
source is with respect
to the join system of the adversary and
the devices so that's that's the setup
of of our
model so what are the goals actually so
before so let's look at expansion
amplification as um physical
extractors um so expansion is simply
seated extraction meaning that the input
X is a is a c is a uniform uh string and
not created with the device or
versary and amplification is a one bit
extractor with some strong assumption
about the
source and I'm going to jump to uh what
are the goals of this model of physical
extractors we want to accomplish a few
goals we hope to have Quantum security
the output should be random uh with
respect to the all powerful Quantum
adversary as opposed to computational
security so we are looking at
information theoretical
security and we hope to minimize error
there are two two two types of errors
and the error of rejecting Hest
implementation and the eror of accepting
uh bad outcome of being fooled by
militia adversary so two types of Errors
will to minimize
and we hope to maximize the upper length
and we want to minimize the requirement
on the classical Source we hope to work
with the broadest possible classical
source and we hope to tolerate a
constant level noise of the devices we
are still not um capable of doing
everything perfect in Quantum so we hope
to tolerate
that and we also want to do things
efficiently uh reducing the requirement
on Quantum memory the number of devices
that we need to separate we need to
restrict communication of and and the
running time should be short so those
are the
goals so now we have this model and our
goal becomes constructing physical
extractors with optimal
parameters so let me State our results
the first set of results this is done
with car car
so this is for seated
extraction so we start with a
small sequence of uniform bits that's
called suppose we have K bits and we
have two devices that we can restrict
the communication between them in the
end we produce exponential in K
bits and it's uh close to UNI random to
the all powerful Quantum adversary so
Quantum security so those aspects match
the result of V vitic so what are the
new
results so the error in our protocol is
negligible in the running time so we
achieve cryptographic security for the
first
time so previous security is only
inverse
polomia so the
error uh so n is going to be the running
time so this is a function that grows
slower than any inverse polomia so T
could be AB large constant could be 100
million so there's a tradeoff between
this
constanty and and this exponent in the
output length but any
TNS uh whose product is less than say
one half um is
admissible so our protocol is also
robust
um if uh the uh the devices are U some
small enough Universal some small enough
constant below optimal uh everything
still
works C there right C plus s that's
right thank you I'm sorry it's typle so
um the corner memory needs only to be
one cubit for each device component and
so the two devices they they play a Lal
game they consume that entanglement but
then they can communicate to establish
new entanglement uh and then in the next
cycle uh play the next game so they only
need to hold one Quantum bit each
component and there are many building
blocks that works in our protocol and
the proof is just complete
different okay that's the first set of
result the second set is done with ch
and and U so this is for SE list SE list
extraction in other words
now we don't have uniform Randomness to
start with we have some endk Source just
one B source which we know classical is
impossible to extract even one bit so
now we have one source and in fact our
protocol works even if the source is
completely known to the adversary so the
Min bek is with respect to the
devices remember we have a restriction
of no communication between them that's
why even if the Verity knows completely
the input he can help the devices during
a
protocol and so this minri K can be arit
small 100 a th000 okay a
constant so our what we accomplish is
basically reduction of cess extraction
to seeded
extraction and uh the construction
tolerates con
level noise and there's some tra up
between the error and L devices and the
error can be made very close to
Optimal so uh I understand I'm running
out of time so I'm going to summarize
some uh implications and I'll be
done so
um the application one application of
our two papers is we can do uh unbounded
expansion and is robust against
noise and
U let me let me jump to the next slide
so here when we put these two papers
together here's a here's a result we
have we can start with k bits of mopy K
can be some up small constant sorry it
can be a small
constant then uh use the second U uh
extractor we get some two randomness of
K bits
and then using unbond expansion protocol
we get up long output and all secure
against the adversary any error is exper
small in K uh which is close to Optimal
the optimal one is to3 minus
k um and we can translate the minip
protocol for generating Randomness to do
key
distribution uh in this case uh we have
a new result saying that uh uh uh Edis
and Bob they only need to start with a
very short uh seed in order to uh
produce uh long shared key and this is
UN trusted device and robust key
distribution
particle so um a physical implication or
maybe a little bit philosophical is that
uh we have a very strong statement about
Randomness in world so uh true
Randomness in nature either either does
not exist or exists in almost perfect
quantity quality and and and unbounded
quantity so we we we are not stuck in
the between world where we only have
Wick
Randomness and we can use our result to
uh mitigate a freedom of choice loophole
in the Bild test by studying with r
Randomness getting almost perfect r and
then run a build test I think I'm going
to stop here because I'm rning out of
time right am I you have still about
seven minutes I I do okay good then at
least I can talk about the open
problems okay so
um I want to talk about methods uh
briefly
um so the foundations of those Protocols
are B test okay and so here's how I
summarize of the building blocks of
those protocols I call it a classical
test of a Quantum
dock if it sounds like a Quantum dock it
works like Quantum dock then it must be
a Quantum
being um so the protocols would be um
classical tests on the devices and see
if those devices behave like Quantum
devices and the test will be uh will
have those properties that are that we
call robust or um then and
caes um column rigid so if those devices
behave so this is the property the
rigidity property if those devices
behave very closely to Ideal Quantum
devices then they must be very close to
the ideal Quantum devices so from the
classical
Behavior we can infer the inner working
must be close to certain ideal Quantum U
behavior and our ideal
devices will be able to generate perfect
Randomness and we know CHS is one such
test and I'm going to skip
that so there's one challenge for
applying uh CHS game for example those
games for for randomness
so remember in in playing C game we
require that the input is uniform to the
devices and we may be consuming other
Randomness U just to get one bit so in
playing a game we need two bits of
Randomness uh so so in in one if you are
outside the field so this this scheme U
that uh we need two bit U as an input to
the devices and we get one bit out so
we're consuming more Randomness than we
get
so that's a
problem and in the case of CES
extraction when we don't have two random
we don't have perect to start with we
have additional problem uh the input to
the to the players to the quantum
players we cannot guarantee to to be a
globally uniform so we our goal is to
generate globally uniform bits and to
play the game those building blocks
require Global uniform bits to start
with so it's a chicken EG
problem so those challenges so one
solution to the first problem of
consuming too much
Randomness is what I call the mixing
work and play I a sixy old and I was
very proud one day I make her through
the dishes at the same time she felt
very uh accomplishing playing um so um
in our setting work is to generate
Randomness but the input is fixed the
input to to to some non loal game is a
fixed z0 I put Einstein between because
uh I restrict these two devices from
communicating in playing a
game so play is to run of the L loal
game with uniform input okay so in
playing it consumes Randomness too much
Randomness but in working it does not
consume Randomness um so one idea is to
mix these two things so that if each
device so so that each device cannot
tell if he is playing or working right
so when the input is zero it could be
working it could be playing so if the
device is trying to cheat trying to uh
uh trying to Output some determinist
outcome then there's a risk of it
failing I think you need a third
Einstein in there between uh
if they could communicate then you could
tell I need a lot of ice
line here yeah so uh here's protocol
from Kuan Vian and it's a adaptation of
uh early protocol by vs
vitic so there we have two devices
playing a lot of games and we choose a
small fraction of those games for
testing consuming very small l of
Randomness and then a lot of Randomness
for uh and then the rest of the of the
rounds will be generating
rounds um and that's that's that's a
protocol that intuitive you think must
work but proving it works uh tends out
to be very
difficult
choosing great uh sure so so this in the
context of seeded extraction I have some
uniform seed to start with they're very
short right so I'm make use of those
coins so that for each round I toss a
very biased coin which probability P I
will choose that
round as a testing R and P is very small
number so therefore I'm going to choose
a small number of rounds but they have
chosen
IID and you don't uh put any assumptions
on how good your your whatever device
you use for exactly that's the whole
point I don't know what's going on in
devices right
so there are a lot of work uh to make it
uh make make the proof uh work so um
there are multiple ideas
involved and we have to put together
several pieces of of puzzle to solve
this
problem um and I want to highlight one
actually I might I guess I'm running out
of time already right okay so so um um
maybe I'll just go to the open problem
uh because those are more exciting for
you uh uh you you may be able to solve
those
problems um if I have to talk about one
single problem okay there are many
problems one single problem is is there
a perfect physical
extractor so earlier I described this
model of physical extractors so they are
multiple parameters by Perfect physical
extractor what I meant is every
parameter is optimized simultaneously
okay or as opposed to there are some
inherent tra between them among all
parameters because that's the major
problem I hope to see somebody solve I'm
going to stop here thank
you yes Joe very nice talk course um you
mentioned at the beginning we need a
trillion bits a day at least at least
according to PR um do you have a sense
of the rate at which you can produce
random that's excellent question hold on
yeah second part of that but how fast
can
you and and what are the limits to
producing as fast as you need okay um I
think it's optimal it's almost best
possible in terms of the bit rate so uh
every basic every basic operation um on
average one operation will produce one
bit a constant bit constant number bits
so in terms of bit rate it's almost
optimal in in in the case of can you
give me a number can you give us a
number uh I think there's a Traer
between uh the air parameter you hope to
have and the outut length um but uh it's
almost optimal but that is in the seeded
case assuming you have some short seed
starways I think it's almost perfect
except for one problem that uh I don't
know uh what is the requirement on a
source like entanglement a major problem
is is it possible to produce true
Randomness without entanglement I
conjecture it is okay but works need to
be done but in the seest case meaning
that when the input is not perfect uh
there's a big room for improvement so we
have to use a lot of
devices a lot of
Einstein uh and which which is which is
not practical and that's where I see big
Improvement can be done or maybe
essentially maybe there's a strong
lbound saying that we can reduce the
devices that's also possible okay and
ask so at the beginning you define true
Randomness in terms of the error
approaching zero yes so I I have two
opposite questions if I put on a a
Microsoft hat I would ask what about
particular you know particular values of
parameters how small do the errors get
and so on if on the other hand I put on
my my mathematics hat I asked how fast
does that asonic approach to zero expect
it to go okay what would you want for
instance in some of these open questions
I guess these two opposite questions can
be answered by me switching a two hats
and then there's there simple answer to
that question but but but more seriously
uh okay uh okay so we have we have two
scenarios right seated and and and SE is
overall I think SE is there's a lot of
room to Improvement for improvement but
in a city case uh the error actually
scales very nicely uh the error is
neglegible function of the up the the
upper lenss it's very nice and I haven't
thought about the Microsoft question yet
but maybe that's that's why we need
industry to work on this as well okay
thank you any other
question guess let thank you thank
you okay so now we're going to
move on to our next
talk so our next speaker is Ben reichart
and Ben's going to speak to us about
classical command of quantum systems so
let's welcome
Ben thank you um yes so this this is
Joint work with fer and with UMES UMES
bazani the main question I'd like to ask
is how we can um characterize and
experimental device
uh you know it's it's a it's a very
General Physics question of course you
run you run tests on it or whatever but
the the difference I want I want to say
is that we want to characterize it with
extremely high confidence so imagining
that you're completely paranoid and you
don't trust anything about this device
and you're worried about loopholes or
people cheating you or um you're really
totally unsure and you still want to be
able to characterize the device and
understand how this experiment works
possibly even control it and there's
there's lots of problems here one one
problem is that any device any any real
experimental system is going to be
quantum mechanical and this means that
if it's an interesting system it's going
to be exponentially complicated
potentially right because just a Quantum
State on end cubits requires potentially
exponentially many n parameters to
describe and furthermore uh we are we
are essentially classical so our
interactions with this with this device
we only get classical information out we
can we can measure the system and we get
some some classical information out we
can measure it again in a different
direction whatever um so it seems like
uh they have this extremely complicated
Quantum system and we were only able to
access it classically and uh it doesn't
give us a lot of hope to be able to to
to be able to solve this problem in in
general
um and and there's other problems as
well so this is sort of related to the
previous talk um a trivial way of
generating random bit is just to prepare
the state uh uniform supervision between
Z and one uh and then measure it in the
computational basis in the 01 basis so
you'll get 5050 Z 50 50
51 um and their problems as we saw like
if if there's some slight bias uh you're
not going to get 5050 you're going to
get
5149 um there's other problems like
maybe when you when you do this twice in
a row there's some correlation between
the bits for for some reason uh the
states are correlated or or there could
be completely crazy things going on like
it could be that actually um the device
was manufactured by the government and
it has a a random string inside in some
tiny little corner of the device that
you can't even find very very very
easily
um and there is not random at all it's
actually deterministic just pretending
to be
random and
so so we'd like we'd like to have the
correct security model and you you you
might imagine that this this is really
too paranoid over here we don't have to
worry that much but the problem is I
think is that it's not so easy to figure
out um where where where you should draw
the line if if you're worried about
security um exactly what what kinds of
uh faults or errors in the devices you
you should worry about you you could
write down a list and you could just
keep on adding and adding and adding to
the list uh so in instead of instead of
that approach I'm just going to start
with the most paranoid assumption
uh security assumption possible which is
that actually the device was
manufactured by by the Enemy by your
adversary and it's it's trying to trick
you and yes this is paranoid but the
advantage is it it um it allows us to
deal with any kind of uh security model
that's weaker we don't have to specify
it too
carefully
um and if you think about it for for for
very long so so here here's here's our
here's my device uh the model is that I
have no idea what what it
does uh it's it's made by the adversary
and if you think about it for for very
long this is completely a completely
impossible problem to try to understand
what's going on inside this blackbox
device when you can only access it by
asking questions and getting
answers
um uh but the interesting thing is that
actually if if you have two of these
blackbox devices and you've at least one
Einstein then then it does does become
possible
so um and so this is really the model
we're going to work with uh I'm going to
work with now I'm going to say we we we
have two blackbox devices that can't
communicate with each other yeah do we
need to assume that the two blackbox
devices are identical no no okay
good I just copy paste it that you have
two devices it's not
one well yeah that's the problem right I
mean I guess you have to assume that
they're um
so I say we have Einstein but in in this
protocol we're actually going to require
lots of interaction so it's not going to
be possible to ensure it despy space by
separating them by by a large distance
you're going to need lead boxes and
stuff like
that okay so
so so here here's sort of what what I'm
going to start with which is this chsh
game um and so here we have we have a
referee this is like me uh the
experiment experimentalists uh and we
have two devices Alice and Bob two
players the way the game works is you
you send them uh each random bit A and B
so it's using two random bits as we saw
and they send they send back their
answers X and Y and to win the game what
they're trying to do is they're trying
to get their answers X and Y uh the exor
should equal the product of of the
questions and if you think if you think
about it if if these devices are
classical devices there's no quantum
mechanics the best thing they can do is
they can reply
zero if they each reply zero the exor is
zero which means that three out of the
four times you're going to equal the
product of a * B the product of a * B
will be zero except if they're both
one um so that's the best you can do
classically you can win three fours of
the time quantumly it's a little more
complicated but here's the best strategy
they can share an epr pair so it's a two
Cubit entangled State uh 0 0 + one one
and they can make the measurements that
I've sort of drawn here depending on
what questions they're asked so then
they just return the results of those
measurements and it turns out if you
look at this picture for a little bit
you can see that uh this strategy wins
the game with probably about 85% it's a
cosine squ pi over 8 is the exact number
and so there's a gap there the quantumly
you can win the game with 85%
classically you can win the game only
with 75% probability and so this this
this this game has been used quite a lot
by experimentalists to test uh quantum
mechanics
um or to test that you have a quantum
mechanical device so what you do is you
you run this test a million
times and you just see how many games
they won right so if they if they win
800,000 of of those games then there
there's probably some quantum mechanics
involved right because classically you
only expect to win 750,000 it's very
unlikely that you'll win
800,000 they could get lucky but it's
very unlikely
um but I I'm going to go much further
than just testing that devices are
quantum mechanical as I said I I want to
understand exactly what's going on
inside these devices I want to
characterize these systems very
well um and so a first step to to to
talk about it is um actually this this
this strategy that wins with 85%
probability it's it's it's essentially
unique um there's only one Quantum
strategy that wins with with the cosine
squ p probability it is this one it has
to use an epr pair so that's sort of
interesting
um I guess it's sort of trivial it's not
that useful we we want to go a lot a lot
further and so what what I'm going to do
is here's our main theorem we're we're
going to try to uh come up with a way of
testing that these two devices have many
uh uh entangled many many cubits worth
of entanglement not just as one uh not
just as one APR pair we we want to show
that they have been very interesting
complicated Quantum
State strategy gives you 85% what if we
lower the expectations 80% yeah so
that's why I say robustly unique so if
it's 85% minus Epsilon then you're sort
of square of Epsilon close to the unique
strategy in some nice metric if it's uh
so that's that's where Epsilon is pretty
small I don't know if like 80% exactly
uh I don't know exactly how the con are
but
yeah actually people people have studied
that though so so they do have graphs
showing like 80% 81% how what Fidelity
you have to have with the DPR pair I
think um
right okay so so here's the theorem that
we're going to we're going to show is um
we're going to consider playing many
games one after the next okay so in
sequence and so what this means is you
know you you send random bits A1 A2 B1
B2 and you get the answers X1 X2 X y1 Y2
and they just have to play each game and
win each game
separately and here's the conclusion um
uh if if uh the devices win um so the
omega star should be 85% or cosine squ 8
if they win almost the optimal number of
the games with high
probability so if if they have a
strategy that allows them to win almost
the optimal fraction games then it must
be uh that at a at the beginning of um a
randomly chosen subsequence of
games uh the strategy for that
subsequence of games has to be
essentially ideal meaning that um so so
so here what I've done is I'm playing
capital N times little n games one after
the next and so you think of it as just
and uh caln's um let's see each of these
is a block of of of a subsequence of
games and what I'm saying is the
conclusion is that if you choose one of
these random blocks then in that block
of little end games they have to be
using um the ideal strategy which which
is to say they have little end epr pairs
in tensor product in the first game they
measure the first epr pair in the second
game they measure the second epr pair in
the third game they measure the third EP
pair and so on so it's actually a very
simple strategy that they have to be
using the you could imagine them doing
almost anything right they they could
have an arbitrary uh entangled state to
start with um they could apply arbitrary
measurements uh the the the the rules
that they use to play the games could
be um completely arbitrary the the rule
you used to play this game could depend
on what happened in the previous game or
the previous game or the previous game
um but this theorem says that that
doesn't
happen you play every game independently
uh and and this is this is actually a
very nice theorem because it actually
does establish that these devices um
have quite a lot of entanglement they
they have to if if if they pass this
test then they have to have at least
little end bits of uh of of
entanglement
um and and so this is this is what we
want to show and unfortunately it's
actually quite
inefficient so the parameters we have is
capital N is polinomial and little n it
has to be
um uh where that Pol where the exponent
of the polinomial is probably I don't
know I don't want to I don't want to say
it's probably like 50 or thousand or
something um and also the error is
pretty bad so so if it's if if you're
winning with probably 85% minus
Epsilon um the error
here um and this
approximate is actually growing like uh
again some some crazy polinomial in in
epsilon yeah I miss something the little
n seems completely arbitrary to me why
did they need little n epr pairs don't
they need little n times Big N epr pairs
to
play intuitively yes but I don't know
how to prove
that uh so so
so little end ised up the end in the
first set of little end games in the
block where did they get the next NE
pairs
from
well so for if if the devices are honest
then then they'll have to start with
capital N times little n epr pairs yeah
if they're dishonest I'm proving that
they have to have at least a little n
okay yeah
uh so so so one one one interesting open
question which I think is quite
interesting in this area it's I don't
know
exactly what the applications of this
are but it's sort of a very fundamental
um question in Quantum information which
is uh exactly how how what the right
kind of error is and how how how it
scales and in particular it would be
interesting if if we could understand um
how to run these kinds of tests if the
noise rate were were constant like which
I guess is more physically um
relevant um and so for example one
conjecture you can make
is that if if you play and little n CHS
games and they win 84% of those games
with high
probability which is something that you
could actually imagine implementing in
in a in a in a in a real world system
then then I my conjecture that they have
to share roughly little NPR pairs
without this crazy uh polinomial
polinomial
loss I have no idea how to prove this
but I think it's a very interesting
question
okay
so so so so I've I've said the theorem I
haven't really motivated the theorem
um the idea is is just you have these
devices you're trying to prove that they
trying to establish that they must have
some interesting Quantum State
underneath them so lots of entanglement
but why why do we want to uh why is this
actual form of of the theorem useful and
so let me let me give one application
there's actually a few of them
um so one application is what's called
delegated computation so in delegated
computation you have like a cell phone
and you're trying it's it has to run a
computation that's um too expensive for
it so it wants to Outsource it to an
untrusted server for
example um and so you want to be you
don't trust a server so you want to make
sure that um the result it gives you is
correct uh and also maybe you don't want
to even tell it what you're what you're
trying to compute
in the first place so classically
there's a lot of results quantumly
um there's what's known before it was
was known as semi- Quantum delegation so
in this in this kind of result uh you
start with some Quantum circuit you're
trying to
apply so for some reason your cell phone
wants to apply a Quantum circuit uh and
you're Outsourcing it to a Quantum
server uh but you can't be fully
classical you you you need to be able to
prepare what one cubit Quantum States
and send them to the server unknown sort
of random one cubit Quantum States and
send them to the server and then the
server does a bunch of processing on
these states and sends you classical
messages and you you to send other
classical messages and that that gives
you your delegated uh Quantum
circuit um actually what we're able to
do is come up with fully delicated
Quantum
computation so you so your cell phone
the weak guy can be fully classical and
he can delegate a a Quantum circuit to
um
untrusted Quantum servers but now we
need um two Quantum servers and and we
need an Einstein between
them and sort of intuitively if if
you're if you're trying to come up with
a scheme like this you might start with
this scheme
here uh and and try to translate it into
this picture so you could have Al uh the
classical verifier and Alice together uh
preparing these one cubic Quantum
States and some somehow and then
teleporting them over to Bob and then
having Bob act as the quantum server in
that
picture uh that's sort of a first
approach um I don't know how to prove
how that works but it's it's I guess
it's sort of an an intuition for how how
you might uh approach this kind of uh
problem what if you have one Ser server
but instead of sending prepared Quantum
States you send perfect random
bids can perfect random Ser
instead play the same role
well um if if if the server is
exponentially powerful then yes it's
it's unknown if the server is polinomial
time Quantum circuit or Quant Quantum
device we don't I don't
know yeah we don't
know that's a good question
though
okay and um sort
of the problem with all these kinds of
schemes is that it's just seems like
it's completely impossible to analyze
them um
rigorously because the the these these
devices could be doing completely
arbitrary things when you when you send
them the when you send them these
classical messages you tell them to
apply gate and you know you tell them
maybe apply this to cubid gate because
that's what you want them to do next and
they apply um you know an arbitrary
unitary on this infinite dimensional
Quantum
State and you have no idea what they've
just done uh you you don't know what
their hbert spaces are uh again it's
infinite dimensional you don't know
their state is it seems like it's it's
really hard to understand what's going
on when you try to give a security
analysis of any of these kinds of
schemes U but the trick is this theorem
for playing multiple sequential chsh
games actually starts to give us a
structure
on on their internal Quantum State they
have to be using epr Pairs and they have
to be measuring them one at a time in a
very nice way and that's sort of like
our foothold which lets us to bootstrap
up to get completely get to get complete
control over anything that these servers
do I think actually the the interesting
thing here is um I I started with I
started with this idea that controlling
Quantum systems is is extremely
difficult um because you know they're
Quantum they're exponentially
complicated we're classical we can only
measure them and so on but actually our
our result turns out to be much stronger
than anything that's possible
classically so if if if you try to
understand a classical device and give
it tests and get answers well you can
verify that it's giving you the right
answers and so on sure but there's no
way of knowing exactly what's going on
under the hood unless you if you can't
open the box it could be doing
completely arbitrary things under the
hood and just giving you the right
answers in some weird way quantumly it
turns out that uh the only way of
passing these chsh tests is if they
share epr Pairs and if they're doing
these particular measurements and the
only way of um okay we'll have more
tests in in a second the only way of
passing these more General tests is if
they behave in these very particular
ways so actually without looking under
the hood we know exactly what's going on
in the in in the states of these systems
so we're getting much more much stronger
control quantumly than is even possible
classically which which is is sort of
interesting
um
right okay
so here I'll I'll give you um I I have a
bunch of other slides on this but here's
like the one slide uh that that's
probably way too short that that sort of
explains how we can bootstrap Security
based on just the sequential CHS AG
games so what we're going to do is we're
going to run one of four protocols at
random
so a quarter of the time or actually
like 99% of the time I think will just
play chsh
games with these two devices one after
the next and and they the these this is
what they should be doing if they play
honestly they should be applying these
measurements okay and and you check that
they win 85% of the games 84% of the
games okay but then a quarter of the
time what you do is you'll run a
different protocol so with Bob let's see
no with Alice you'll keep on playing the
CHS games so you you'll send her random
bits zeros and ones and she'll have no
idea um that device will have no idea
that you're not in this picture playing
chsh
games but with Bob you'll ask him you
won't ask him to play chsh games at all
what you you'll instead ask him to make
some interesting
measurements in particular he'll ask
them to um prepare certain States on his
halves of the of the of the share D PR
Pairs and the point is
um Bob now can can cheat our arbitrarily
you have no idea what Bob's really going
to do but you know that Alice is still
playing the chsh games and so you can
use her measurement results for those
games to tomographically verify that Bob
does what he's supposed to be
doing and similarly in in the third
protocol we're going to have Bob playing
the hsh games and Alice we're going to
ask Alice to do some interesting
measurements on her halves of the states
and
um uh again so Bob's results will sort
of give us a tomographic uh test of that
that Alice is behaving
honestly yeah just a question about
about terminology is do you think
control is exactly the right terminology
for this given that uh Alice and Bob
could just arbitrarily decide not to
play the game and jam the
protocol right
uh I don't know so I think actually did
I call it control here I call it command
but I don't know yeah yeah right the
devices can always just decide not to
cooperate there's nothing you can do
yeah so so so all there's always an
assumption that if the devices pass
these tests then they must yeah this
resembles prison dma situation I hope
not well no I don't think so I mean that
the the devices should always be trying
to defect in in our
analysis
uh we're assuming that they're trying to
be dishonest both of them um and they
just
can't um sorry so so there's our
protocols so the first protocol is just
the games uh then we have one protocol
where Alice checks Bob one protocol
where Bob checks Alice then finally in
the last protocol we just uh plug
together this part where where Alice is
doing interesting things and Bob is
checking and this part where Bob is
doing interesting things and Alice is
checking so now we put this and this
together so so Al and Bob are both doing
interesting things but they have no idea
that the other person is in check them
so they have to keep on playing just as
they were in these two
protocols and and finally now they're
both doing interesting things they have
an interesting State they have these epr
pairs that's a pretty interesting state
so they can do really interesting
computations you can do an arbitrary
Quantum circuit um by by teleportation
is is a trick so so this crazy picture
here actually implements this very
simple circuit
here sorry you can you might be able to
see that it'll take like 10
minutes a question so from Bob's
perspective the information sets are
such that Bob cannot distinguish between
uh A and C uh but they he can
distinguish whether he's either an A or
C or B that's right whereas Alice It's A
and B are indistinguishable C andb are
indistinguishable that's right yeah but
they're all sort of tied to each other
exactly
yeah so that you can not only force them
to do the computation but they won't
neither of them knows what computation
they yeah that's that that's actually
very easy I mean up to sort of like
they're going to know like the size of
the computation unless you try to you
know blind it Som like buffer it or
something um but yeah essentially uh you
just so in computation by teleportation
you need you just need to ask one of the
players to prepare these resource States
like hadamard Gates and c not Gates and
whatnot and the other player sort of
links them up but they have no idea how
they're being being linked up so they
they know how many gates they're they
know how many gates the circuit has but
they have no idea how they're wired up
at
all oh that's what you mean well I sort
of was
ask
uh yeah I don't know how you could stop
that right because after the fact they
know as much as you
know
yeah
all right all right so that's that's
sort of how how this starts to be useful
um so maybe how how long do I
have we have about or 21 minutes oh okay
that's good so so so maybe um unless are
more questions about this instead I'll
I'll go back to to the theorem and and
start to explain um sort of the
difficulties in in understanding a
theorem and and proving a theorem for
for for just the CHS
games
um let's
see so so the proof actually has has
three steps the first step is just basic
classical statistics so you say um if if
these devices win 85% of the games with
high probability what that means is that
if you look at a um a random block of uh
polom many
games uh uh then it must be that every
single one of those games you have to
have played that game uh with 85%
winning probability it's just sort of
like a sampling thing and and this is
sort of necessary I mean for example the
these two devices Alice and Bob they
could decide that at the very they could
decide in advance that they're always
going to cheat in game number five and
statistics they're always going to
return zero in game number five and
there's nothing you can do about that
you can't force them to use an epr pair
in game number five um you can just say
that sort of statistically you can avoid
that by saying if I look at a random
game or a random block of games you're
missing game number five and in that in
that block they have to be playing
pretty
well okay okay so so now there's three
steps all right so so the first step
says that in every game that they play
uh they have an epr pair that they're
using or a state that's close to an epr
pair that they're using and so there's a
cubit on Alice's side and the Cub on
Bob's side sitting inside their Hilbert
spaces so this is just a picture this is
supposed to be Alice's Hilbert space
it's some infinite dimensional space and
these balls are each supposed to be a
cubit and um they sort of overlap
because we don't know how the cubits
relate to each other at all and
furthermore there's there's mult there's
lots of cubits so the the game one cubit
is here in game two you have maybe two
or four cubits depending on the outcome
of game one and in game three Alex could
use any of I guess four cubits but I
think it's actually 16 um depending on
the outcome of the first two games and
so
on so that's the first step of the proof
is establishing that they they are using
cubits hidden inside their Hill bird
spaces but we have no idea how how these
cubits relate to each other and there's
tons of
them the second and most interesting
step is to start to show a tensor
product structure so so here I I I
showed that the Cubit used that Alice
uses in game two is in tensor product
with the Cubit that she this in game one
so it's sort of like an independent of
of what happens in Game one and so in
the picture they're not overlapping
anymore but again potentially she uses
different cubits in different games
depending on what happened in the
previous games and finally um in a sort
of a technical step we we we showed that
actually uh there's no history
dependence so the Cubit they use in the
in game two does not depend on what
happened in game one game three does not
depend on game two or game
one
but the most interest interesting step
is actually showing that that these
cubits don't overlap each other that
they're intenser product and I should
just say that this kind of picture where
cubits are balls and overlapping means
they're not intensive product this is
completely misleading and you should not
like you should not think too too
closely about what this picture means I
mean if you have an infinite dimensional
hbert space a cubit is not a ball a
cubit is really um what is
it
uh you know you have to choose a basis
and and say this is this is my key it so
I guess it's like a hyperplane which is
like the poly X measurement and another
hyperplane which is a poly Z measurement
and they should be at like dihedral
angles of 45 degrees between these
between these planes
everywhere um so they're not like balls
at all and if you have two cubits they
they don't overlap you just have these
hyperplanes sitting around in different
directions um but it's still nice to
think about it sometimes
right so it's it's hard to appreciate
how many things can go wrong with this
kind of
theorem uh pretty much anything you can
imagine so like first of all we don't
know that they're playing using epr
pairs there's no way of establishing
that that these devices use exact epr
pairs because all we have to test them
is statistics so we can only say that
they're using close to epr Pairs and
this is always a problem because if
they're using close to epr pairs then
the errors can be sort of arbit and they
can overlap each other in small ways and
then the air is can start to blow up
very
quickly um so so here's kind of here's
kind of a picture I have games 1 through
seven that each have slightly
overlapping cubits and the problem
you're worried about is that game eight
uses a cubit that completely overlaps
game one because somehow the errors have
accumulated by by in the in those seven
intermediate games that now they're not
in tensor product or even close to being
in tensor product
anymore so it's I mean it's fairly easy
to show that if you just have two games
one after the next they have to be
almost in tensor product but the
question is how far you can push that
kind of
statement um so so so here here's a
here's one way that erors accumulates so
I've drawn four cubits I'm going to use
uh five let's
see yeah so so I'm gonna play five chsh
games using five epr pairs so one two
three four five
uh but in actually in game one I'm not
going to use this first DPR pair I'm
going to use most of this erpr pair in a
small fraction of the last tpr pairing
in game two I'm going to use most of the
second one in a small fraction of the
last one in game three I'm going to and
so on and so by the time I get to game
four I've accumulated enough air over
here that maybe move this cubid all the
way into like some other position like
back into this
position um
because because that's just how the air
is that's the direction that the errors
were going and so in game five I
actually started I measure this Cubit
again a second time I measure the same
Cubit and because the epr repair has
moved into that position so this is kind
of a um a non-tensor product strategy
it's it's not not the ideal strategy um
but and so it would be a counter example
to our theorem if this if this were
allowed um and you can say how can this
happen well first of all the errors are
adding up and there's Pol uh many games
in in our actual system not not five but
it's even worse than that because every
time you make a measurement um any error
gets
renormalized when you measure Quantum
state so so you take your state s you
measure it you get Pi SI than some
renormalization Factor if there was an
error then the error is also blown
up and so this is this is another
problem and there's lots of other
reasons why a is accumulate this is just
a first
example
so
um let me sort of give you
uh I don't think I'll go into any detail
really but let me just give
you uh very high level intuition for for
why this this might work or and and how
the proof works and
actually the idea is that Alice is
Hilbert space we know nothing about
Alice's silver space Bob silver space we
know nothing about that but the one
thing we do know is that Al and Bob are
in tensor product with each
other and and that is sort of the key
thing so we're going to use the tensor
product structure between Alice and Bob
to find to construct a tensor product
structure um substructure within Alice's
silver space and within Bob Silber space
and and so the trick is um we have two
tricks that we're going to use so the
first one
is these are both easy to verify so the
first one is just if if you take an epr
pair and you act on the first half
that's that can just as well be done on
the second half so so this is an
identity if m is any uh 2x two Matrix
that's the identity 2x two Matrix and
you multiply this out uh it's this is
true you get M transpose on the
right so an operation on Alice's side is
the same as an operation on Bob's side
the
transpose the second fact is that
quantum mechanics is local so anything
Alice does actually can't affect um what
Bob has in expectation
right so so if if you don't conditional
analysis measurement result then Bob has
no idea what Alice is doing you
can't all right so so so how are we
going to use this
um let's see so so we're we're playing
end
games and let me just try to show that
game n is sort of independent of game
one uh game n is intenser product of
game
one so so first of all they they play
the first game and they collapse this
first DPR pair so now this is like a
measured cubit and then they play games
two thr
minus come
on two3 N minus one and then they came
game play then they play game n and
we're worried about a situation where
game n has somehow wrapped around and is
using the same cubid again
okay so what we're going to do is we're
going to use Fact one to pull these
games to pull Alice's operations in
games two through and minus one over to
Bob's
side um when that means is by Fact Two
uh uh this Cubit here cannot be affected
by Games 2 through n minus
one because um anything done on Bob's
side can affect Alice's state so it
can't affect this Cubit so what that
means is that after n minus one games
this Cubit is still collapsed it's still
whatever it was after the first game
like C zero or C plus or
something and so therefore when we play
game n this Cubit is just like cat zero
or something it's completely useless in
the chsh game it has it's not an
entangled Cubit or something and so
therefore game n has to use has to be
using a fresh cubid in some other
direction that's that's the idea and so
so that shows that game n has to be in
tensor product the Cubit us it in game n
has to be used in tensor product of the
cubit in game one even though a bunch of
stuff happen in the middle and lots of
erors
accumulated that's that's sort of the
idea of of how the whole proof works you
obviously you have to be more careful
because we're trying to show that
everything's in tensor product not just
end with one but this is this is sort of
the biggest
idea
um let's
see right
so I I I have a few slides here which
sort of show uh explicitly they they
construct the tensor product uh
structure within alysis Hilbert space
and and show how that's
done um
where that came from
uh but I I don't I don't know if that's
sorry uh but I don't know if that's so
interesting unless unless there's
questions about that
um it's interesting to me
um maybe maybe let me just in instead
finish up or ask if ask if there any
questions maybe I just answer a question
yeah so so uh I'm trying to see if I can
come up with different way of Cl showing
your result Suppose there some point I
can argue that um for the little end
sequential F I know that um um everyone
condition on the previous UPC is some
tiny Epson away from from from I and can
I just say that overall they are 10
times um away
from no I don't me
so um because the tens
produ need
more
sequential no I mean I just it's it's
uh
yeah because ER there's no reason erors
to just add up errors errors can blow up
much faster than much faster than that
if it
doesn't
how I think trivially like let's see yes
there is something you can say but it
might be like double exponential or
something like
that
yeah okay I mean because well there's
one exponential just from
renormalization and there's another
exponential as well um at least another
exponential which which I guess probably
comes from this second point which I
erased okay yeah so so that that that
biger monster function is it constructed
mean that is suddenly it could be out
bound
but have you thought about some excit uh
training strategy that set
that
conditional um
prop yeah I think I think this is very
interesting open question as well
because it's um coming up with counter
examples to these kind of theorems is is
very hard right because you have to come
up with some very interesting Quantum
State that's highly entangled it's not a
tensor product state but it lets you
sort of cheat in some interesting way I
don't know how to do this I I wish I had
better ways of coming up with counter
examples that that would be just as
interesting as as a
theem
question if not let's thanks thanks Ben
thanks